scp-682 versus scp-524  the hard to destroy reptile versus the  cuddly widow bunny named roki that can  eat pretty much everything does 682 look  enough like a big angry carrot for  walter to get the job done 682 regarded  walter with suspicion as the bunny  approached it it then began gnawing  through 682's leg causing the giant  monster to bellow and flee he chased 682  around the containment chamber for  several minutes before 682 tapped out  682 climbed up the wall of the test  chamber and waited while walter washed  his face with his paws 524 then began  chewing his way through the wall of the  test chamber at which point the  experiment was aborted still very good  try little buddy